the next day I head south past Ho Chi
Minh City and into the Mekong Delta this
fertile region is crisscross with
hundreds of waterways
[Music]
it's home to a floating food market
where I'm heading to learn a Vietnamese
classic that's essential to my culinary
education inside this market is a lady
he's a bit of a legend she hasn't a
reputation for her brats and if I'm
gonna get up to speed quickly within a
week about Vietnamese cooking the broth
is the harpy
the broth Queen mrs. Z hai is a veteran
she's been selling her suit for 40 years
and today are rolling up my sleeves to
work with her morning
chef Luke noon is here to help too
so she's a master of Roth's she's the
master of broth so let's go check it out
there the only way to do it is to get in
there and do it yourself I'm gonna fill
in that boat you are and I am as well
it's true it was a bit rocky Jesus right
see I thought was the equivalent of a
market cafe and a suit recipes the
ultimate in fast food and now she's
gonna teach me how to make it so the
broth where did the original recipe come
from is it from a mum just from eating
she eats on the street eating these
little stores and she trains a pallet to
make it the best that she can on this
floating river here yeah what's she
sorting out there so we've got banana
blossom there yeah bean sprout yeah and
it shredded water spinach stems yeah and
try some vermicelli noodles behind you
yeah so here we just got some hot water
hot water just gonna be a laptop okay so
she cooks it very very quickly now in
Vietnamese cuisine the clearer with the
broth the bitter right I mean looks like
it doesn't have much flavor but you're
sipping it's just yeah very complex see
highs trick is to put the dish together
in seconds to ensure it retains its
Vietnamese crunch quickly thank you
well now is delicious and the fragrance
of the herbs at the end as well yes love
that coriander the sweep as a texture
balance of flavor
lightness vietnamese cuisine in a
nutshell there for you there's no more
time for me to practice today
I take mrs. Z highs place serving her
regulars she needs to sell 60 to break
even 60 volts young 80 bowls to make
some money okay
so roughly she'll make around how much
they go for less than a dollar less than
little in a dollar so we're looking at
fifty pence we get to work this is how
she advertises a dish he sings it out so
she's saying both dishes but she sings
in this melodic tune it's quite
beautiful to this room
[Music]
durian [ __ ] me how far southern in the
morning singing for your breakfast Hotel
hotel sixty portions a day Milioti we're
gonna do 80 today let's make us some
money look at them rushing no one
portion soldier lazy to go what mrs. Z I
spent most of her life working this
patch but I could ruin her reputation in
just one morning thank God for that
customer okay all right finally bean
sprouts no no no she's a bit more be
morning bit more so let's say a regular
person yeah
no no thank you don't want to first one
of the day hotel boom-boom
Jesus huh trouble why there was a PID
she once Jesus come real come on wake up
sit it's been testing she's happy
this is serious drafting beyond belief
incredible where we sold 20 portions yet
and not just a speed you've got to work
out but I'm being something tainted all
into one little spot here cooking
without moving I've never known making
sink to be so difficult
these broth is a triumph and I'd like to
do it justice thank you no Chile thank
you
what do you think okay no very quiet is
she's seen a customer that's it
someone's called her over
excuse me
[Music]
this is hot hard work and I only managed
to sell a fraction of what Zi serves up
every day please enjoy thank you tell
her I'm a chef
in the UK and I've never sat still and
had to cook in one place for so long a
bang-bang would hear quite funny doing a
bake car she said do you think it's hard
work this yeah this is this is beyond
hard work I've been to lots of it means
restaurants in London yep and the Ross
and the soups absolutely fine but
nowhere near as delicious as this yes
your are amazing lady
a few days into my adventure and I've
got a brand new respect for Vietnamese
food he was right mastering this cuisine
in a week is gonna be a tall order I'm
nervous because I wasn't blase but I I
thought Vietnamese food was similar to
Thai but it's completely different so I
think it's gonna be harder to understand
than any other country I've ever visited